>>> THIS IS NEW YORK.
THE MELTING POT OF OVER THREE
CULTURES, AND FOOD IS ITS
UNIVERSAL LANGUAGE.
>> MY NAME IS ROCCO.
>> HEAVY CAT.
>> AND MY NAME IS DONALD TRUMP.
WE MOVED HERE FOR COLLEGE, AND
WE'VE BEEN HERE EVER SINCE
EXCEPT FOR COVID.
>> TODAY, WE'RE GOING TO SHOW
YOU OUR NEW YORK, THE REAL NEW
YORK, ONE BITE AT A TIME.
>> THIS IS STREET EATS.
TODAY, WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
JAMAICAN PART OF THE CITY,
JAMAICAN QUEEN, AND WE ARE ON
THE HUNT FOR SOME AUTHENTIC JERK
CHICKEN.
>> AND QUEENS MAKE SOME NOISE!
>> RICE, THE STINKING MAN'S
CHIPS.
>> WHAT THE HELL ARE Y'ALL
DOING?
>> WE'RE JUST HERE TO FIND OUT
WHAT JA-MAKES YOUR FOOD SO
SPECIAL.
>> GOT IT.
SO Y'ALL JUST MOVED HERE FOR
CONNECTICUT, RIGHT?
YOU HAVE TO STOP YELLING.
>> WELL, I NOTICED YOU WERE
SELLING DELICIOUS JAMAICAN FOOD,
BUT YOU YOURSELF ARE NOT
JAMAICAN.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> NO, I'M JAMAICAN.
>> HOW WOULD THAT BE --
>> SPOTS LIKE THAT ARE EXACTLY
WHAT MAKES NEW YORK SO GREAT.
TACO, OH, SPICY.
>> SO YOU WANT JERK CHICKEN WITH
NO CAYENNE, NO CUMIN, SALT,
PEPPER?
>> NOPE, CAN'T DO IT.
>> SO YOU JUST WANT A BLANK ASS
PIECE OF CHICKEN?
>> WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
>> IN NEW YORK.
>> NEXT, WE DECIDED TO HIT UP A
NEW YORK STAPLE, SO WE HEADED
ALL THE WAY UP AND WE WALKED
HERE BECAUSE WE COULD NOT FIND
THE ONE SAY.
>> KEEP GOING THIS WAY?
>> RULE NUMBER ONE, YOU'VE GOT
TO ORDER LIKE A NEW YORKER.
HEY, YO, BOSS, LET ME GET SOME
MAYO AND BREAD.
>> HEY, THERE'S A LINE.
>> I GOT IT.
HEY, FORGET ABOUT --
>> MY FATHER IS A LAWYER!
>> CAN'T CUT THE LINE, MAN.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ALL DAY.
>> WELL, I HOPE THE BUILDING
YOU'RE WORKING ON EXPLODES.
THEY HATED US THERE.
BUT AT LEAST WE HAVE FRIENDS IN
THAT FAKE JAMAICAN LADY.
SHE LOVED US.
>> I HATED THEM, BUT I READ THE
COMMENTS ON THEIR VIDEOS, AND NO
ONE SHOULD HAVE TO READ THAT
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
THE NICEST ONE I SAW SAID GAY
FAIL.
I MADE THEM SOME PLAIN ASS
CHICKEN, AND THEY LOVED IT.
>> AUTHENTIC JERK CHICKEN.
>> WHAT A BEAUTIFUL NEW YORK
DAY.
WE HAD SOME CHICKEN.
NO ONE CAN DO IT LIKE US.
>> NEW YORK!